[Music]
from the company behind all the worst
toy stories comes the exciting prologue
to the gi joe franchise and also the
other exciting prologue to the gi joe
franchise after that first one didn't
hit because after two films showing us
how it all began it's time for the joe
burst to
get another exciting prologue again
knowing is half the battle the other
half is knowing when the battle is
supposed to start
gi joes one and two
remember the classic gi joe cartoon and
action figures kind of before your time
okay well they made two movies about the
guys from the pork chop sandwiches video
pork chop sandwiches
and they're like team america but
without the jokes
[Music]
damn i missed him also before your time
well i know what to tell you then is sir
pinto are in fortnite but with the same
company as the transformers toys behind
the project they're gonna follow that
same old formula mixing generic military
dudes and hot military babes with a
bunch of cgi nonsense yet it never
really comes together see michael bay
knew that the secret sauce was racist
robots what are we going to do with this
shrimp taco this bubble cap in his ass
no not not me i do not mean mudflap i do
waste two hours meeting channing tatum
as duke a performance with all the
easy-going charm of a man who's there
against his will detail that's him son
because he was i hate that movie i so i
was pushed into doing that movie he's
playing a sad potato who ghosted his
fiancee after getting her little brother
killed yet we're still supposed to like
him
but not for too long because he's only
in the sequel for 10 minutes before he
hands it off to his oldest pal the rock
uncle duke wait wasn't his lifelong best
friend marlon wayans what happened to
ripcord did all the workplace sex
harassment finally catch up with him hmm
i'm attracted to you when i get a target
in my sights
i take it down we are tough but well
also sensitive watch the rock's
reputation as franchise viagra go down
like a flaccid windsock and he's getting
zero help from ray park in yet another
voiceless role bruce willis doing the
least to collect his check as is
tradition and joseph gordon-levitt for
the first movie at least as my chemical
cobra commander the inspiration for
deadpool makeup design like a testicle
with teeth
ride along with two stories that feel
like they were stolen from a little
boy's notebook margins featuring twists
like bad lady good now good guy bad now
and uh oh bad guy good guy in scripts
that fail all the way down to the
sentence structure g.i joes they're
about to be out of the picture
and by out of the picture
i mean
alive on earth
that's not what out of the picture means
think war toys are just for the boys so
does hasbro but dang it they're gonna do
their best to sneak in some ladies where
they can girl scout to secretary amazing
awkwardly don't make me shoot a woman
get out
nice shoes very awkwardly goodbye
sweetheart
that's right you don't kill women he
didn't want to put his life in the hands
of a woman really very awkwardly amy
vanderbort fox oh fox of course
that's why you look so fair and balanced
very cute you think it it doesn't
so long as they still promise to dress
all sexy
[Music]
and when a fight breaks out only square
off against the other woman even if that
means fighting an old lady
experience two films that can't even do
american propaganda right where the army
keeps getting its ass handed to them
bongs their own troops and doesn't
notice when their own president gets
swapped with a shapeshifter for months
meanwhile the joes do nothing but get
beat up have their stolen get arrested
and let everyone in london die
like 9 million people dead sorry big ben
so before you see snake eyes empty so
before you scroll past snake eyes on
some streaming service revisit the films
that already gave you a perfectly
reasonable snake eyes origin story he's
a lost member of the wu-tang clan but in
order for me to bring him to justice you
must deliver him to me alive who spent
his entire childhood beating the crap
out of another kid
kid fight kid fight kid fight hit fight
kid fight kid fight kid fight kid fight
kid fight kid fight kid fight get fight
kid bite kid fight kid fight get bite
get bite get fight get bite kid fight
kid fight kid fight kid bite kid bite
kid
sadly this is the best part of the whole
franchise
kid fight kid fight kid fight
starring
g.i chode
i'm hunting cowboys
inventor of the fidget spinner the price
is wrong
dwayne the walk away from explosions
johnson
fight chicks
scarjo
my trooper ex-girlfriend the quaid
redemption
we all live in the high-tech submarine
high-tech submarine high-tech submarine
i'm going to sew storm shadows out shut
and just keep feeding him and feeding
him
brendan fraser for one scene why and
more cisco than the thong song
apparently unknown well one thing's for
sure
only minor injuries to report sir
knowing half the battle
[Music]
body massage origins
wow an exploding motorcycle you have to
jump off of to use that's probably the
worst weapon in history
there's only one thing i hate more than
lying skim milk which is water that's
lying about being milk
you're a bread compartment
country home take me road to a belong
where i am place
hello nurse